E aí
oi oi
e eu tenho andado meio nostalgica
ultimamente Esses dias eu tava lembrando
da minha época de estagiária como é que
o ritmo era outro e eu lembro que eu
chegava no escritório apertar o botão do
computador e demorar um pouquinho até
ele ligar e ainda tinha que me conectar
com a internet eu trabalhava no
departamento de comunicação e ele dava
com imagens pesadas e toda vez que eu
colocava uma dessas imagens para salvar
eu levantava e ia tomar um cafezinho ou
então conversava com as pessoas de tanto
que demorava
é só que hoje de repente num piscar de
olhos tudo mudou o mundo anda veloz em
certo Complex umbigo as exigências
aumentaram e com ela a necessidade de
fazermos as coisas cada vez mais rápido
e eu tentei acompanhar toda essa
agilidade só que o que eu não esperava é
que eu precisasse fazer uma pausa
forçada independente da minha vontade eu
estava numa carreira internacional em
atenção quando foi Surpreendida por um
diagnóstico psiquiátrico é que em março
de 2005 eu fui diagnosticada com
transtorno bipolar com características
psicóticas no início quadro na Hora bom
as perspectivas menos ainda eu tive um
médico inclusive que disse que eu
deveria me aposentar por invalidez
Imagina você eu tinha 30 poucos anos com
tanta coisa para viver pela frente
quando uma parada Total acontece em
minha vida no caso do transtorno bipolar
eu
a sugestão de comportamento um a
depressão e outra Euforia que antes era
chamado de mania na fazer o fórmica era
uma energia sem igual eu lembro que eu
ia para o escritório trabalhar voltava
de madrugada e continuava trabalhando
como se isso fosse a coisa mais normal
do mundo até que meu chefe me disse
Jenner dá uma acelerada os outros
departamentos não estão aguentando a sua
demanda aí eu comecei a piorar e eu não
conseguia enxergar as coisas direito era
como se eu colocasse meu rosto para fora
de um carro em alta velocidade e não
consegui distinguir os objetos uma vez
eu olhei para a geladeira e vi vultos
cores formas até hoje eu dou uma olhada
na geladeira para ver se ela tá
paradinha no lugar Às vezes a filha tava
minha audição também eu escutava coisas
que ninguém mais escutava como uma bola
de basquete batendo incessantemente do
meu lado meu maior medo naquela época
o que será gradativamente Até deixar de
ser quem eu sempre foi e depois da sua
energia toda provocada pela Euforia eu
caindo uma depressão avassaladora nessa
fase era muito difícil eu me senti uma
inválida eu chorava o dia inteiro tem
nenhum aumento aparente Eu lembro que
uma vez a gente fez uma festa de
aniversário para o meu marido e eu não
conseguia levantar da cama eu lembro que
eu orei roguei barganhei mas o meu corpo
não respondia isso é muito atípico
porque eu sempre fui uma pessoa
extremamente sociável e agir daquela
forma não era muito o jeito que eu era E
aí momentos como esses vi uma verdadeira
culpa de não poder fazer as coisas com
tanta facilidade e junto com a culpa
vinha uma vergonha uma tristeza uma
agonia imensa
Oi e essa agonia continuo vocês a ser
bando até que uma vez eu gostaria de
dormir e nunca mais acordar comecei até
planejar esse meu desaparecimento se é
que vocês me entendem e eu falei isso
para minha terapeuta E ela me disse
genes são perigo você tá tendo ideações
Suicidas e essa palavra conheço bem a
minha avó cometeu suicídio aos 56 anos
de idade e ela também tinha transtorno
bipolar e a minha terapeuta sugeriu que
eu fosse por um Hospital Psiquiátrico e
esse termo Hospital Psiquiátrico assusta
qualquer um só que para mim o que
assusta muito mais é o estigma é o
preconceito porque assim impede com que
as pessoas busquem o tratamento adequado
e eu fui para o hospital onde eu tinha
pessoas me avaliando 24 horas por dia
pessoas profissionais médicos
competentes e isso me ajudou muito a
melhorar
e eu saí do hospital eu acho que o que
me fez o meu maior bem foi poder contar
com o apoio e o amor incondicional da
minha família eu lembro que uma vez no
hospital e eu cheguei para o meu marido
e falei amor se você quiser se divorciar
de mim eu até entendo eu nesse momento
não tenho nada para te oferecer e ele me
disse tá doida que eu vou me divorciar
de você quando eu respondi bom que eu tô
doida está muito bem pré-estabelecido a
gente está no Hospital Psiquiátrico e o
tempo foi passando a minha vontade de
melhorar continuou e eu comecei a
visualizar visualizar a minha
recuperação que nada mais era do que uma
visão otimista de quem eu queria ser e
me imaginei estudando trabalhando
fazendo as coisas que eu sempre gostei e
aí eu lembro que foi janeiro de 2007 e
resolvi fazer uma resolução de ano novo
escrevi no papel e disse que eu faria o
possível e impossível eu me
comprometeria para
a realizar e superar esse transtorno e
nessa época eu comecei a ler todos os
livros sobre transtorno bipolar de todas
as biografias e o que eu aprendi naquela
época é que as pausas não são
permanentes na verdade a pausa é uma
excelente oportunidade para descobrir
reservatório de potencial que a gente
nem sabe o que a gente tem e de alguma
forma eu acho que todos nós estamos
passando por uma pausa forçada por causa
do covid-19 em um momento muito dolorido
mas eu acho que se a gente prestar
atenção a gente vai conseguir tirar
lições riquíssimas nesse momento tão
difícil no fundo Tudo Começa dentro da
gente não são os fatores externos que
geram estresse e sim como a gente lida
com esses fatores externos e eu presto
muita atenção no stress porque pode ser
um gatilho para os meus sintomas e a
depressão transtorno bipolar são doenças
seriíssimas de acordo com a OMS a
depressão é maior causa de incapacitação
do mundo e pesquisadores de oxi
o que quem tem transtorno bipolar tem
uma expectativa de vida de 9 a vinte
anos a menos e eu sempre penso como é
que eu posso ficar fora dessa
estatística
a primeira coisa é sabendo que eu não
estou curada e sim estabilizada isso faz
com que a adesão ao tratamento seja
ainda maior e a outra eu acho que tem
muito a ver com a alta responsabilidade
que é esse meu comprometimento com a
minha saúde mental em adotar hábitos
saudáveis ao longo prazo e até curioso
né alguém que tem um transtorno mental
chegar aqui para vocês e falar sobre o
equilíbrio à Vida Saudável mas faz todo
sentido do mundo Saúde Mental para mim
não opção é uma questão de vida ou morte
que se eu não me cuidar a minha
probabilidade de me suicidar aumenta
exponencialmente é por isso que eu vim
aqui hoje dividir cinco passos que eu
faço para complementar o meu tratamento
vou dar um exemplo para vocês lembra que
na época de Euforia eu falei que meus
pensamentos eram extremamente rápidos
isso acontecia muito eu acho que essa
nossa mania de viver ocupado é uma
adrenalina que Vicia
o final do dia a gente pensa nossa eu
trabalhei tanto mas eu tenho a sensação
que eu não fiz nada é que pesquisadores
de Stanford Descobriram que quando você
faz multitarefas a sua eficiência sua
produtividade cai Nossa cérebro é muito
parecido com um computador sabe no
computador quando você deixa todas as
abas abertas o nosso cérebro é igual e
no fundo a nossa atenção consciente é um
dos recursos mais preciosos que nós
temos e lá em 2007 quando eu Prometi a
mim mesma que eu iria cuidar da minha
saúde mental a primeira coisa que eu vi
foi sobre a meditação e aí eu tentei eu
morava em rios ou na época aí eu fui
para um templo budista aprender a
meditar e eu confesso para vocês eu fui
um verdadeiro desastre essa concepção de
esvaziar a mente focar na respiração não
pensar em nada aquilo não era para mim
eu já cheguei por bom hoje e falei olha
eu entendo da importância da meditação
mas eu acho que eu não tenho capacidade
cognitiva para isso e ele me disse com
toda aquela Calma que só o monge tem DN
meditação não é uma coisa que a gente
faz meditação é uma coisa que a gente
prática e ele tinha razão e eu resolvi
praticar e até hoje eu percebo que
quando eu não medito eu não durmo tão
bem e a minha capacidade de foco e
concentração diminui EA minha ansiedade
aumenta e essa falta de foco falta de
clareza que eu tinha me foi ajudado pelo
meditação mas não eram os únicos
sintomas um dos outros que eu tinha
muito Evidente era minha necessidade de
isolamento
e eu acho que é compreensível né quem
tem depressão sabe que é uma angústia um
desespero que você quer se afastar do
outro você não quer que o outro veja
você daquela forma Então você se afasta
só que quanto mais difícil fica nossa
vida mas a gente precisa do outro acho
que eu tenho uma vez que mostra existem
no escuro mas quando você acende a luz
você vê que mostra então existem só que
às vezes você não tem aquela força para
levantar e acender aquele interruptor E
aí que você precisa da mão amiga e
quando eu decidi que eu ia melhorar eu
comecei a investir nas meus
relacionamentos esse foi meu segundo
passo e aí eu montei o meu grupo com
minha família meus amigos cheguei a
frequentar vários grupos de apoio e isso
foi muito importante para mim
ah e hoje eu vejo que o isolamento
impera a gente tem tanta tecnologia para
nos aproximar está cada vez mais difícil
nós fumarmos relacionamentos sinceros
duradouros e talvez ainda mais difícil
da gente conviver com pessoas que pensam
diferente da gente e o que a gente
deveria realmente fazer é até cada vez
mais relacionamentos inclusivos mas
diversos Porque quanto maior a
inclusividade adversidade maior
possibilidade da gente encontrar
soluções para os problemas mais
complexos que a humanidade oferece será
colaboração mediada pela tecnologia que
nós conseguiremos atingir índices mais
altos de inovação e esta tecnologia vem
com alguns desafios pelo menos para mim
um deles foi a sobrecarga digital e dá
para entender a gente vive em frente às
telas o dia inteiro
a minha tela do computador da televisão
do celular estudiosos da Universidade de
Chicago disseram inclusive que que a
gente sociais viciam mais do que o
álcool e do cigarro e para me ajudar a
equalizar essa sobrecarga digital eu
priorizei o sono na minha vida se na
época da depressão eu dormir 18 horas
por dia e na época de Euforia eu não
dormia hoje eu sei que 7 8 horas é o meu
ideal o som da restaurativo ele
potencializa a nossa capacidade de
aprendizado e memória e nos ajuda também
a diminuir alguns tipos de câncer
diabetes e doenças cardiovasculares e eu
lembro que quando era mais jovem eu
achava o máximo virar a noite
trabalhando e hoje eu sei o compra
judicial isso fez a minha saúde e dormir
melhor foi a terceira coisa que eu fiz
para melhorar minha saúde mental a
quarta foi um exercício e eu sempre usei
a falta de tempo como desculpa
e até que um amigo meu me disse gênio um
dia tem 1.440 minutos se você não
encontrar 30 para se exercitar você tá
vendo fazendo alguma coisa errada e ele
tinha razão e eu comecei a ver o
exercício como prescrição médica como
algo que fosse me ajudar a combater as
minhas comorbidades e quando eu comecei
a ver o exercício dessa forma ficou
muito mais fácil vencer a procrastinação
e sair do sofá e eu acho que a
procrastinação é algo que todos nós
temos algum tipo de familiaridade às
vezes é tão difícil tirar os nossos
sonhos do papel que a gente tem tanto
medo de errar eu escutei uma vez em
algum lugar do mundo tem um museu da
procrastinação lá tem aquele livro
incrível que nunca foi escrito aquela
tela genial que nunca foi pintada e
aquela inovação brilhante que nunca foi
patenteada a gente tem que lembrar uma
coisa a vida é bem diferente da escola
na
o primeiro a gente tem a lição e depois
a gente tem a primeira a gente tem a
lição e depois a gente tem a prova e na
vida primeiro a gente tem a prova e
depois a gente tem a lição e para contra
cor essa procrastinação imposta pela
doença eu precisei de muita disciplina
para fazer os quatro passos que eu
contei hoje aqui para dormir melhor para
me exercitar para meditar para buscar
relacionamento saudáveis E foi com essa
disciplina que eu seguir em frente eu
precisei pausar até andei para trás mas
eu continuei hoje eu posso dizer que o
transtorno bipolar me transformou
e eu não reclamo do meu trabalho porque
eu sei o que que está em capacitado eu
sei que imprevistos acontecem com
qualquer um e que aquele senso de
controle que eu achava que eu tinha era
uma mera ilusão também reconheço os
privilégios que eu tive um deles para
acesso à Medicina de qualidade e o meu
desejo mais sincero é que todas as
pessoas que têm o transtorno mental têm
acesso às mesmas facilidades que eu tive
e eu já faço que eu gosto eu sou
diretora global de marketing para uma
empresa de inteligência informação e
através de um livro eu contei uma
história o nome do livro a invenção da
mente e eu coloquei no gerúndio de uma
forma proposital porque eu trabalho
Nunca Termina e contar ela minha
história assim tão abertamente para
verdadeiro desafio eu fiquei com muito
medo de ser ridicularizada estigmatizada
ou até excluída Mas isso não aconteceu
eu fui tratado com muito carinho da
Nayara
um livro que contar para o meu chefe e
eu achei que eu fosse demitida ou então
que minha carreira e acaba naquele
momento e ele me surpreendeu quando eu
disse Gene coragem autenticidade
vulnerabilidade são características de
verdadeiros líderes isso foi muito
importante para mim para seguir em
frente por um momento eu cheguei a
pensar em publicar o livro de forma
anônima mas aí eu perderia excelente
oportunidade de mostrar para as pessoas
que é possível sim viver com transtorno
mental e viver uma vida plena e reforçar
a importância do tratamento para que
isso aconteça não foram foi assim com
hábitos saudáveis autoconhecimento
disciplina que eu consegui virar o jogo
e retomar a velocidade lembrando a
importância da pausa seja ela proposital
não foi através da minha pausa que eu
consegui me conectar com quem eu
realmente era e contei a minha história
com a minha própria voz não sabe um dia
disse-me
é mas vai devagar que é mais importante
do que a velocidade EA direção que você
vai então começa Onde você está lá no
seu próprio ritmo e nunca desista até
encontrar o seu ponto de equilíbrio
obrigada
E aí
[Música]